BREAK IN.
I'M TRACE GALLAGHER.
NOW BACK TO HANNITY.
WELCOME BACK TO THIS SPECIAL
EDITION OF HANNITY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP VERSUS THE
OBLIVIOUS LEFT.
SHE IS BACK AND DESPITE
BEING URGED TO GET OUT OF
SPOT LIGHT BY POLITICIANS
AND PUNDITS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE OBLIVIOUS HILLARY
CLINTON WON'T GO AWAY.
AFTER FACING HEAVY CRITICISM
FOR HER DEMEANING REMARKS
ABOUT TRUMP VOTERS WHILE IN
ASIA, THE TWICE FAILED
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE IS
ONCE AGAIN LASHING OUT.
DURING A PAID SPEECH AT
RUTGERS UNIVERSITY, CLINTON
COMPLAINED THAT THE RECENT
CRITICISM LAUNCHED AGAINST
HER IS BECAUSE SHE IS A
WOMAN TAKE A LOOK.
>> PEOPLE SAYING GET OFF THE
PUBLIC STAGE AND SHUT UP,
WHICH IS SOMETHING WE ARE
HEARING ALL THE TIME.
>> YEAH.
HOW DO YOU --
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THAT
BEGAN TO HAPPEN AFTER THE
ELECTION.
THE ELECTION WAS PRETTY
TRAUMATIC.
[LAUGHTER]
I WAS REALLY STRUCK BY HOW
PEOPLE SAID THAT TO ME.
MOSTLY PEOPLE IN THE PRESS
FOR WHATEVER REASON LIKE OH,
YOU KNOW GO AWAY, GO AWAY.
PEOPLE WHO WORKS FOR ME GO
BACK AND DO A BIT OF
RESEARCH.
THEY NEVER SAID THAT TO ANY
MAN WHO WAS NOT ELECTED.
BUT I DO WORRY THAT WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS THAT IT'S BEING
HELD CAPTIVE BY A VERY SMALL
GROUP OF POWERFUL FORCES.
WE HAVE SEEN THE POWER OF
THE NRA, FOR EXAMPLE.
>> Judge: WHILE HILLARY
CLINTON CONTINUES TO BASH
REPUBLICANS AND PLAY THE
GENDER CARD, HER SPEAKING
FEES ARE TAKING A HIT.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THE
$25,000 HILLARY CLINTON
RECEIVED FOR THE SPEECH YOU
JUST SAW WAS ACTUALLY $7,000
LESS THAN RUTGERS PAID
JERSEY SHORE REALITY TV STAR
SNOOKI.
SO, JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION RNC CHAIRWOMAN
RONNA MCDANIEL.
RHONA.
I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE
THING.
HILLARY CLINTON KEPT SAYING
IN THAT SOUND THE PRESS KEPT
TELLING HILLARY GO AWAY.
WHAT I FIND SHOCKING SHE
WROTE THEM OFF DURING THE
CAMPAIGN?
SHE HAD THEM ALL ROPED OFF
SO SHE WOULDN'T HAVE TO TALK
TO THEM.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON HILLARY
AND WHAT SHE IS DOING IN THE
PUBLIC SQUARE?
>> WHERE DO WE START?
SHE IS SO WILLING TO PLAY
THE SEXIST CARD WHEN, IN
REALITY, SHE IS BEING
TREATED EXACTLY LIKE ANY
OTHER NOMINEE WHO WOULD HAVE
CONTINUED TO DENIGRATE HALF
OF THE COUNTRY, WHO WOULD
CONTINUE TO FAIL TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FAILINGS OF
THEIR CAMPAIGN AND THE OTHER
THING SHE DOESN'T
ACKNOWLEDGE IS WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROVIDED FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHICH
WAS A VISION OF MORE JOBS
AND HIGHER WAGES.
SO BY CONTINUALLY REFUSING
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE FAILINGS
OF HER CAMPAIGN AND WHY SHE
LOST.
SHE IS HURTING HER PARTY AND
HER PARTY IS SAYING PLEASE
GO AWAY, YOU ARE HURTING US.
NO OTHER PREVIOUS NOMINEE
HAS PUT THEIR FOOT IN THEIR
MOUTHS AS MUCH AS HILLARY
CLINTON HAS SINCE THIS
ELECTION ENDED.
>> Judge: WHAT'S INTERESTING
IS WE NEVER THOUGHT THAT
THAT CLINTON MACHINE WOULD
EVER BE CONFRONTED BY
SOMEONE AS DARING AS SOME OF
THESE POLITICIANS TO SAY YOU
KNOW, MAYBE IT'S TIME FOR
YOU TO GO AWAY OR IF
YOU TO GO AWAY AR IF
YOU TO GO AWAY AS IF
YOU TO GO AWAY AS I SAY GO
BACK IN THE WOODS.
THE TALK ABOUT MIDTERMS
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION FIRST
TERM I SHOULD SAY USUALLY
BENEFITS THE OTHER PARTY.
BUT, NOW, WITH HILLARY
CLINTON, AND THIS LOON
CIRCUMSTANCE HER SAYING THAT
THE ELECTION WAS TRAUMATIC,
YOU KNOW, DOESN'T THIS
BENEFIT REPUBLICANS?
>> IT DOES.
AND I DO THINK THE PEOPLE
WHO AREN'T TELLING HER TO GO
AWAY ARE THE DEMOCRAT
LEADERSHIP.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM CHUCK
SCHUMER OR NANCY PELOSI.
WHAT SHE SAID WAS TRULY
INSULTING TO SAY THAT WOMEN
ONLY VOTED FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP BECAUSE OUR HUSBANDS
TOLD US TO, THAT IS SO
DENIGRATING TO SAY THAT WE
ARE AGAINST
AFRICAN-AMERICANS HAVING
JOBS AND PROGRESSING IN OUR
ECONOMY.
THAT IS SO INSULTING.
WHAT SHE HAS SAID SHOULD BE
DENOUNCED BY CHUCK SCHUMER
AND NANCY PELOSI AND THESE
RED STATED DEMOCRATS NOT
HEARING FROM JOE DONNELLY,
BILL NELSON, WHERE ARE YOU?
IT'S INTERESTING THAT THE
DEMOCRAT LEADERSHIP IS NOT
DISTANCING THEMSELVES AS
VOCALLY AS THEY SHOULD BE
FROM THE VERY INSULTING
COMMENTS OF HILLARY CLINTON.
IT IS GOING TO HELP US IN
THESE MID TERMS.
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT
ONLY PUT FORWARD A VISION IN
THIS ELECTION, IS HE
DELIVERING WITH PEOPLE
GETTING BIGGER PAYCHECKS AND
MORE JOBS COMING BACK.
PEOPLE FEELING GOOD ABOUT
THEIR LIVES.
SPEND ARE MORE ON THEIR
FAMILIES.
I NEED TO RETURN REPUBLICANS
TO OFFICE.
BECAUSE THEY ARE DELIVERING
FOR ME AND MY FAMILY.
IT'S
>>'S
>> Judge: NOT JUST RETURNING
REPUBLICANS TO OFFICE BUT
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
LIKE-MINDED LIKE
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
GOING FURTHER ONLY GOING TO
BENEFIT CAN DATION TO AT
LEAST TALK THE WAY
ENTREPRENEURSHIP DOES.
>> OF COURSE.
LOOK AT WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS DONE.
ISIS IS ON THE RUN.
OUR MILITARY IS BEING
FUNDED.
HE CARES ABOUT OUR BORDERS
AND OUR LAWS.
HE CARES ABOUT OUR JUDGES
MAKING SURE THEY ABIDE BY
OUR CONSTITUTION.